اصدر مجلس الوزراء السعودي يوم امس
موافقته على تسميه عام 2023 في عام الشعر
العربي ومن جانبها اوضحت وزاره الثقافه
السعوديه ان تسميه
2023 بعام الشاعر العربي تهدف لاثراء
الابداع الشعري المتطور والمستدام ايضا
كذلك وتعزيز ما كانت الشعر العربي في
ثقافه الفرد بالاضافه الى ابراز المكون
الحضاري الشعري وتجدره في تاريخ الجزيره
العربيه
معناها من الرياض الرئيسيه لهيئه الادب
والنشر والترجمه الدكتور محمد حسن علوان
دكتور محمد مساء الخير حياك الله معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وداني اسفل في
البدايه بعد ان وافق مجلس الوزراء على
تسميه هذا العام عام 2023 عام الشعر
العربي لماذا تم اختيار الشعر العربي عام
مساء النور وشكرا للاستضافه بطبيعه الحال
لم ياتي هذا الاختيار تاكيدا للقيمه
المحوريه للشعر العربي في ثقافه العربيه
بشكل عام والبعد تاريخي والامتدادات
الجذريه لحضوره الشعر خصوصا في ثقافه
الجزيره العربيه التي كانت وما زالت موطن
للشعر والشعراء همم عبر القرون همم طويل
وياتي عام الشعر العربي تحديدا بعد عامين
قامت من خلالهم وزاره الثقافه بالاحتفاء
بالمكونات الثقافيه الاصيله في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه همم عيشنا عام الخط
العربي وبعد ذلك عامل القهوه السعوديه وكل
ما يعكس اعتزازنا بالهويه الوطنيه
والعناصر الثقافيه السعوديه والعربيه وذلك
ياتي بطبيعه الحال تحقيقا لمستهدفات رؤيه
المملكه 2030 التي تتضمنت ابراز الهويه
الوطنيه الثقافيه السعوديه ضمن
المستهدفاتتها
بالحديث عن المستهدفات ما الذي تهدف اليه
الوزاره وزاره الثقافه في المقام الاول
وايضا كمان هيئه الادب والنشر والترجمه من
يعني اختيار الشعر العربي هذا العام حتى
يكون هو عام همم او حتى يكون عام 2023
عاما للشعر العربي
نهدي في تحديدا لا تعزيز مكانه الشعر
العربي في ثقافه الفرد اثراء الابداع
الشعري المتطور والمستدام وابراز المكون
الحضاري الشعري الحاضر في تاريخ الجزيره
العربيه تحديدا كما تعلم الجزيره العربيه
همم هي الموطن الام للشعر العربي الجزء
الاعظم من تاريخنا الشعري حدث همم في
الجزيره العربيه شعراءنا العظام همم عاشوا
في الجزيره العربيه وكتبوا همم تاريخ همم
الشعر بشكل عام في الجزيره العربيه ولعلنا
نهدف من هذا العام الى تصنيط الضوء على
هذا الحضور التاريخي للجزيره العربيه في
عالم الشعر وامتداداته عبر همم مختلف
مناطق العالم العربي بعد ذلك بالتوفيق لكم
يا دكتور شكرا جزيلا همم لك من الرياض
الرئيس التنفيذي لهيئه الاداب والنشر
والترجمه الدكتور محمد حسن علوان